Mein Name ist Uwe Sauer,
bin 66 Jahre alt,
habe den Beruf eines Ofensetzers erlernt,
war 20 Jahre im Beruf.
Und heute bin ich altersarmer Rentner
mit 66 Jahren und kriege nur 321 Euro.
Wir mussten schwer arbeiten, vom dritten,
vierten Hinterhof, fünf Treppen in Kreuzberg,
Öfen abreißen, Kacheln neu
rauftragen, Lehm einrühren,
da musste ich die Öfen neu setzen,
das war eine Knochenarbeit.
Mein Kreuz ist auch kaputt, meine Knie auch,
das berechnet heut keiner.
Ich habe 2013 einen
schweren Autounfall gehabt,
habe hier neun Schrauben
im rechten Bein und zwei Platten,
und danach war ich dann erwerbsunfähig.
Und … was soll ich sagen?
Und nachher wurde
das Bein immer schlimmer
und dann wurde ich dann nicht mehr
vermittelt.
Wir kochen hier für
120 Essen im Schnitt täglich,
und in der Woche gehen noch an die 500
Liter Eintöpfe
an verschiedene soziale Außenstellen.
Hier kommen hauptsächlich Menschen
aus sozial benachteiligten Schichten,
Leute, die wenig Geld
zur Verfügung haben
im Monat, um ihre …
ja, um ihren Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten.
2019 waren in Deutschland
3,2 Millionen Senioren ab 66 Jahren
von Altersarmut betroffen.
Als arm gilt, wer weniger als 60 Prozent des
Durchschnittseinkommens hat,
das sind monatlich 781 Euro. Warum?
Zu geringe Löhne früher,
zu lange … zu große Zeiten der
Arbeitslosigkeit,
insbesondere nach dem
Umbruch in den 90er-Jahren,
gebrochene Erwerbsbiografien,
und das führt letztendlich
auch zur Altersarmut.
Es ist das absolute Armutszeugnis,
dass in einem Land wie Deutschland
überhaupt diese
fast schon industrialisierte Tafel existiert
und dass man den armen Menschen über
solche Institutionen praktisch
den Lebensunterhalt gewährt mit.
Einmal wöchentlich gehen Uwe Sauer
und seine Frau Elaine einkaufen.
Nee, die können wir uns nicht leisten.
Oder doch – 99 Cent.
Na, dann nehmen wir so eine, 99 Cent.
Das ist eine Paprikawurst, Paprikasalami, die
kostet 99 Cent,
sind 400 g, und schmeckt sehr, sehr lecker.
Und von dem Geldbeutel,
weil wir wenig haben,
können wir uns die leisten,
und es ist mehr drin als in anderen Filialen.
Dann nimmst du das – Kekse,
guck mal, dann hast du was Schönes.
Man hat sich dran gewöhnt, mit wenig
auszukommen,
ich bin ja nun Rentner, wie gesagt.
Man braucht nicht so viel,
um glücklich zu sein.
Gesundheit ist das Wichtigste auf Erden.
150 Menschen kommen jeden Donnerstag
zu dieser Ausgabe der Berliner Tafel.
Wir haben hier seit über 15 Jahren
eine Lebensmittelausgabe
für Leute, die
zusätzlich Lebensmittel brauchen,
weil sie staatliche Leistungen kriegen, die
eben auch nicht so richtig reichen.
Ich finde es ganz gut, dass es das gibt,
weil es natürlich, ich denke,
in jeder Gesellschaft auch Leute gibt,
die irgendwo durchs Raster fallen.
Also, ich denke, hungern muss man nicht,
wenn man sich nicht schämt eben,
so ein Angebot anzunehmen,
aber Altersarmut gibt es schon,
weil manche Leute eben doch sehr, sehr
geringe Renten haben,
wo man eben auch
nicht wirklich gut von leben kann.
Ich bin ein bisschen bedürftig,
aber ansonsten schäme ich mich nicht dafür.
Armut schändet nicht.
Nein, ich schäme mich nicht mehr,
ich habe mich dran gewöhnt.
Die Liebe ist größer als die Armut.